this is from the daily wire it says
not even it's not even june yet and
already corporations are signaling their
allegiance to the progressive lgbt
agenda the latest seemingly unaffiliated
brand to come out in support of the
cause is none other than oreo cookie
which has been owned by the
multinational food and beverage
conglomerate mundo is international
since 2012.
um the marketing team at oreo
couldn't wait until pride month to put
out a new commercial spot which featured
a young man coming out as gay to his
grandmother this is an oreo ad first of
all before we play this ad or a little
bit of it uh as mentioned in the article
like you you
we're a couple months away from pride
month
and it gets more extravagant with each
passing year but
especially with what's happening in
florida and everything else you cannot
even imagine
the sheer intensity
of the virtue signaling that we are
about to experience once we get to pride
month it is going to be like unlike
anything
i don't know if any of us will survive
the month without cringing to death
because what we're about to play here
with this oreo ad
this is oh this is just an appetizer
um so let's play a little bit of this go
ahead
okay well the ad is not in english
either so this doesn't really translate
for an audio podcast but
all i can tell you is i watch the ad and
it's like it's like 75 minutes long
and
the oreos appear in it one time
okay this is all about so this this
guy's he's gonna he's gonna come out of
the closet to his grandmother
uh there's the oreo so the oreo does
make an appearance
right before he's about to come out of
the closet they take some oreos
and then his grandmother comes in okay
all right we're seeing enough of that
[Music]
you know i could almost all right i
don't even want to see it turn off um
i could almost
i'm not going to say
respected but i would be somewhat
impressed with all these virtue
signaling lgbt ads if you could find a
way
within the ad to tie it back to the
product like that would be
impressive i'd actually watch the ad
just to see like how do you get there
how do you bring this back to
advertising for a cookie
but they don't even bother to do that
anymore
this is it seems like a small thing but
just the fact that um
every major conglomerate every major
corporation in america
are tripping over themselves i mean
they're they're even discarding their
own messaging
forget about forget about advertising
their product
the primary point of this ad this is a
very this is a very new thing because it
used to be that
yeah advertisers they would seize on
social issues and that kind of thing to
sell their product but the primary
message in the advertisement was always
about the product it was it always came
back to buy my product
you know pepsi and coca-cola do this
kind of thing all the time about hey you
want to teach the world to sing and it's
a peace and harmony but
how do you
bring peace and harmony to the world
it's by it's by drinking pepsi or
coca-cola whatever that ad was
now they've gotten rid of that the ad is
not even about the product
the ad is simply to affirm their
allegiance to the lgbt
cause and that is when you know you have
power in the culture that's when you
know you have privilege
when you have major corporations who are
even
discarding their concerns for the bottom
line in profiting for the sake
of
bending the knee to you
that's perfect
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated